ما نشرح موقعك اكسبريس جاء على شكل نصائح
نسبيه من الطبيبه الامريكيه جوليا جونز
والتي تؤكد ان تاخير تناول طعام الافطار
او ما يعرف بالصيام المتقطع هو نمط حياه
يساعد كثيرا على الحفاظ على الجسم بشكل
مثالي ويطير العمر طبيبات تؤكد ان جسم
الانسان بحاجه للراحه لنحويه 16 ساعه من
اجل ان يسمح للجهاز الهضمي والمسرات
الخلوي الاخرى ان تنظم نفسها وترتب
وظائفها لكن على النقيض فان دراسه جامعه
ان الصيام لا يمكن ان يكون الطريق
المثاليه للجسم البشري لانه عند الاكل قد
ياكل الانسان بشكل زائد عن حاجته وبالتالي
لان يكون هناك اي فائده منه فكره الفريق
البحث في جون سابقا تقول ان الاهم من
الصيام هو حساب عدد السعرات الحراريه
المستخدمه في الاكل وهي الطريقه الافضل من
اجل قيام بحميه تساعد على الحصول على وزن
الاقل